I sold my catalog voluntarily for a load
of money okay and for those trying to
understand how that works see when you
getting royalty stream it's income so
you're taxed at a 50% rate if you sell
your catalog it's at a capital gains
rate of 15 to 20% so if you get the
right multiple so they say oh you're
pulling in a million dollars a year on
your catalog will give you X years in
advance you and your account look and
you go okay so I can have $10 million
now or I can wait at 20% and take that
money and invest it or I can get it
hopefully every year because you never
know some years you're less some years
you're more for the next 10 years at 50%
so I'm only getting $500,000 instead of
getting $800,000 I know there was you
told there be no
math but and you sit there you go okay
this is the point where I sell and I do
that